you know there's a creator for this
beautiful creation
there is a Creator stop pretending like
you don't know
hey season doesn't make any sense you
know the atheist
they come and try to criticize Islam
Islam this and that but as an atheist
you believe everything is subjective
there's no absolute truth
that's absolute truth
what is absolute truth
so there's no doubt that I'm human being
left okay so now
does something come without me Creator
if something came to existence
is it possible for non-existent to
create something
good
atheists
so this creation good creation this you
believe in the Creator
okay who created this creation
it's always existed so Define universe
are you part of the universe
okay you never existed
you didn't exit all the time you never
exist all the time
not just you that she has it every part
of universe has a finite it's all these
happens in my body
blindfight you said what billion years
a million years ago
okay is that true is that true after
truth okay how do you know that
cannot tell you that because if
something happened billion years ago
science cannot tell you that because
what is science the method of science is
a collection of data through observation
and it has to be reputable you have to
repeat over and over again and yes
just said we don't know the sign is not
true it's science you are suggesting a
billion years ago some billion years ago
you're suggesting the entire science of
cosmology is false because humans I did
not say that I said to say it's not
acceptable finish the sentence
scientists that cannot tell you for a
fact what happened 500 years or 4
billion billion years ago that's called
assumptions you know it's not science
it's called a belief this is called what
assume as reason to believe
no that's not because like it's
impossible irrational illogical atom can
create a human who has a morality who
has all of that doesn't make any sense
of course any human being okay
okay is it possible that the Earth
create human being like yes okay how can
we never in a history heard Earth gave
the best to human beings
[Music]
[Laughter]
to show you you know there's a Creator
but you know you you have no problem to
accept any Theory as long that theory
does not need to Creator who has to tell
you to follow this electricity okay
rationality tell us that's why Richard
Duke when he was corned how come we have
not seen and observed this towering
Evolution for million years humans been
around why we haven't seen something
one species evolving to completely
different species no adaptation
completely to different species you know
what he said Orchards
yeah he said due to the lifespan because
you don't have a long life that's why we
kind of see it you know what it means
I'm lying to you so I'm gonna deceive
you because you have a long time so for
for for many years human existed and
there's no time for a woman to give a
bath to Monkey there's order order does
not come by random oh that doesn't come
from just an atom like that that's what
Allah told us what created the Earth was
gravity gravity gravity gravity what's
created humans
wait wait wait so Lucas is I Told You So
what created the Earth is what gravity
but you told me it's Eternal always
existed I didn't say that I said the
universe and the Earth is part of the
universe
that's why they won't accept any creator
you're saying that because I have a
finite lifespan and I am part of the
universe yeah consistent with the
universe
doesn't it you said I was created
correct
by gravity yeah okay gravity is an
entity that's a force okay it's a force
so so therefore you believe in the
Creator
ability created gravity he didn't say
that he said that even arrogate now take
care of yourself remember you would die
and you stand before Allah all these
excuse that you try to use to turn away
from God Allah benefits you you're
getting older fill Allah
cultures existence
yes
that has energy that has a power ability
to choose how to create a creation he's
saying therefore saying that that I
believe in creators when I talk about
somebody who created the cake I'm not
I've your death Source rage is to create
the universe we'll talk about even the
Earth okay
this is the Earth part of the universe
it is now yes
deep down you know doesn't make any
sense you know why because any human
beings with a sound reasoning and
removing arrogance looking at this all
the evidence order and we never had a
woman give it back to a chicken or a
chicken giving a birth to right oh that
was the organized order let me finish
and finish I know he's here to New let
me finish everything I know is the truth
everything that's what Allah told us
in the creation of the heavens and the
earth and the alteration of a day and
night it is a sign for people
understanding if I said to you this
phone was made by by a sin you know uh
you'll be crazy what about yourself and
myself it's impossible illogical will
create without any Creator who possess
knowledge and power take care of
yourself too late bye-bye